how do you interpret what the are nice
Bloomberg scoop about the ECB ela I
think this would be exploding the figure
to Greece and saying you have to present
some reforms and you have to do this as
soon as possible the mail Evan your
group meeting may be the last date they
species as acceptable so that a grease
can present a full list of reforms that
bode well with what the craters want to
see I think they're saying enough is
enough at the moment you have to
understand that the basic be fans by for
74 billion euros the grid banking system
it keeps it afloat through the ELA there
is a buffer of around 3 billion euros on
that ela amount and at the moment with
the decree that was passed yesterday by
the Hellenic Republic 2 billion euros
are going to be transferred from the
commercial banks to the back of grace so
there is the ELA buffer is going to be
down to 1 billion euros and that is
really a small amount of money to have
other side mario's how would you read
the situation the pressure is being put
on Greece from every quarter at the
moment the Germans the same we don't
expect a deal the IMF saying no you
can't extend your your payment story the
ECB may be thinking about increasing
haircuts on on the ELA kind of put all
that together for me I think it's
increasing the pressure on on both sides
actually it's not just grease I think we
should be in a situation where both
would want and desire a solution and and
the ECB is simply in telling them that
we're running out of time and you cannot
expect us to keep giving you more and
more time the ECB has been fantastic in
the way it has managed the crisis over
the past few years they have given a lot
of time to government's important
politicians with their OMT back in 2013
to do the right thing and politicians
and governments have simply not
delivered so the sooner they come up
with some sort of agreement the better
but so far Europe has never fed missed
the opportunity to miss an opportunity
Mario so yeah that's probably very well
put if you look at
timeline and it's unclear to me because
actually of course these keep on
changing we don't know exactly how much
money Greece has but I was reading an
interesting report from one of our
Bloomberg economy saying actually they
have until July the end because it's
unlikely that the ECB will do anything
with the ELA until it can't repay the
monies to the ECB and that comes July
twentieth yes I think so i think they
might be able to gather enough cash for
the next few payments that are doing the
next couple of months but for the july
payments around seven billion euros it
is to the ECB there's simply not enough
cash going around for that there will
need to be a plan before that vasilis
are the local authorities and the
central government working hand in hand
here it depends on what party you're in
other the mayors of some very large
cities that don't belong in syriza I
really have expressed this content on
this our decision however I there's not
much to be done they have to put the
cash in the bag of ways we see let's
just talk us through I mean you know
sometimes it's difficult as a market
participant to exactly understand the
integrations of politics how likely is
it that we go to fresh elections because
there's a faction within the syriza
party that is against everything that
the government is even doing at this
point the so-called left platform of
syriza the radical left of syriza sees a
way for a grace outside the euro and
they have been saying it openly and
directly tsipras it tries to maneuver
between them and what the creditors are
looking for there is a very interesting
opinion poll that just came out today
and I quick papers and it shows that
positive opinions for how the government
is dealing with it the bailout talks is
less than fifty percent right now this
is down from 75% just a month ago so as
a Greek default looms probably elections
or a strict referendum or whether it
stays in the U or not is the only
solution to go I'm very funny quote you
back one of your research notes if
Greece goes can Portugal stay I think
it's a it's it's going to be difficult
for other countries as well the
fundamental building block of the common
currency is that it is irreversible we
had pegs before the euro we had the VA q
before the euro it was never sustainable
because it was never credible because he
was not irreversible and if an
arrangement can be reversed well it will
be reversed the euro was supposed to be
forever if one country lives why can't
another so I think the question will
come to the markets who's next and I
think it's it's it changes the nature of
the euro and we can never go back to
what it used to be it's not forever if
one can't really get it is reversible
their answer the question chem
Portugal's day of Greece goes I don't
think it's going to be an immediate
effect but if it Greece goes and and
Greece begins to recover and I think
there is a chance that it could recover
after it leaves then why wouldn't the
the electorate of other countries put
pressure on their own countries the
policy in Europe the policy of austerity
is not working it's a misdiagnosed cure
that the Europeans up subscribing and it
hasn't worked